In this last lecture of this
unit, we continue with some of
our earlier themes, and then
introduce one new notion, the
notion of independence
of random variables.
We will start by elaborating a
bit more on the subject of
conditional probability
mass functions.
We have already discussed the
case where we condition a
random variable on an event.
Here we will talk about
conditioning a random variable
on another random variable,
and we will develop yet
another version of the total
probability and total
expectation theorems.
There are no new concepts
here, just new notation.
I should say, however, that
notation is important, because
it guides you on how to think
about problems in the most
economical way.
The one new concept that we will
introduce is the notion
of independence of
random variables.
It is actually not an entirely
new concept.
It is defined more or less the
same way as independence of
events, and has a similar
intuitive interpretation.
Two random variables are
independent if information
about the value of one of them
does not change your model or
beliefs about the other.
On the mathematical side, we
will see that independence
leads to some additional
nice properties
of means and variances.
We will conclude this lecture
and this unit on discrete
random variables by considering
a rather difficult
problem, the hat problem.
We will see that by being
systematic and using some of
the tricks that we have learned,
we can calculate the
mean and variance of a rather
complicated random variable.